crazy banana
you are first what is up
you are definitely first
what is up trempatrev hello
oh now they're coming in hello everybody
welcome welcome welcome welcome
it's very late slash early depending on
where you are right now
everybody ready hey woof woof
are we ready what time let's see 13
minutes this is going to be
the halloween episode i kind of know
what is gonna happen but i also don't
know
what's gonna happen you know so we'll
see
i have a good i i would say
if the episode is let's say it's 30
minutes long
then i probably know
like seven minutes of what's gonna
happen so i don't like
entirely know everything that's going to
happen
i know just like a small part let's make
sure audio and everything is right
good sweet awesome awesome awesome
everything looks good looks like you
guys can hear me
i know i need sleep too hey uh
michael bachar i hope i pronounced that
right thank you so much for the donut
3 a.m yup it's late it's 2 a.m for me
right now
um yeah it's it's late but hey
these are what the fans do right this is
what we do
because that's what heroes do
edward norton's version of the
incredible hulk he is nuclear physicist
ooh that would be kind of cool
but we but i wonder who they we're
we're talking about aerospace engineer
you know so i like wonder who that's
gonna be
you know but we'll see i don't think
that's coming to like episode nine
like literally episode nine
you look like you're cold yeah i don't
so so some people have been saying
that hawkeye is going to be the cameo
and that
that i don't want to say that can't be
the case but it can't be the case
because vision and hawkeye have already
appeared
in the movie together which means paul
bettany and jeremy renner have
worked in a film together so if paul
bettany is talking about somebody that
he's always wanted to work with
it that's not jeremy renner because he's
already worked with jim jeremy renner
so it can't be a hot guy i i do think
hawkeye might make an appearance
just because of his connection to wanda
um
but he's not the big one that paul
bettany was talking about because he's
already worked
with paul bettany so they can't they
can't be him
and nick fury confirmed episode six um
i think nick fury's on vacation right
now um
because remember at the end of
spider-man far from home which is
confirmed now to take place
after one division he's on what i'm
going to assume is
the peak which is like the sword
headquarters in space located like
kind of just outside of earth so
i don't know if nick fury's gonna make a
cameo maybe talos
disguised as nick fury maybe the scrolls
are involved somehow which like you know
i'm kind of thinking they are involved
in one way or another and i
i'm thinking that maybe maybe the
aerospace engineer
that that monica was saying that she
knows
maybe that's talos's daughter that we
met in captain marvel
i don't want to say it's that because i
want it to be somebody bigger
but it could hey ooh what's up zens
but it could like
um what's the word um
continuity wise makes sense
um if it was talus's daughter that's
that's the aerospace engineer and i also
like
like i was watching a new rockstar vid
because i love eric voss and i love
zach over new rockstars and those guys
are awesome um
and they were talking and they were
saying like they hope like
that little aerospace engineer nod
wasn't like
a way to kind of like introduce the
fantastic four like that wasn't the
first easter egg drop like they were
hoping it would be bigger than that
like maybe say fantastic or something
like that
uh we don't really know at this point
i'm hoping it's
one of the three well four originals
i hope it's either hugh jackman's
wolverine which
like i don't see why they would do that
with the exception of
you know like for the fans you know
fanfare
i would freak out i would go crazy if it
was
hugh jackman's wolverine but i i don't
think it really makes sense
continuity-wise story-wise
and they have to make it make sense
so the next one would be
patrick stewart's professor x i'd love
for him
to appear at the end somehow and maybe
he forms like the illuminati
right because i've talked in a few
videos it's been a while since i've
talked about the illuminati but i'm
talking a few videos about the
illuminati
and i think they're coming a few
different reports from a few different
people have said that they're coming
so that would be really cool
but then there's magneto which i think
makes the most sense
um you know in the comics at one point
in time they retconned it to where
wanda and petro's pair both they don't
talk about the mom but
that is actually magneto hey lone wolf
what's up man
yeah yeah i i'm hoping for that
lone wolf and thank you so much for the
dono um i'm hoping for that
i'm hoping the aerospace engineers read
richards because there's nobody smarter
than him
in the marvel universe um not tony stark
not bruce banner not shuri
although you never know what they're
going to do in the mcu right um
but magneto just makes the most sense
because in the comics he's the father of
the twins wanda
and petro um then you could also
introduce the x-men
now there's a little bit of debate here
is it going to be
you know which version of magneto is it
going to be ian mckellen
bass midnir you know which one is it
going to be
um michael fassbender magneto
i liked i didn't have any problems with
i actually don't mind some of the x-men
movies that people hate now there
are some that i think aren't really that
bad like i went to dark phoenix and i
really wanted to like it like i really
thought i was going to like it
i was like everybody's just hating on it
because that's what they do
but i didn't like it and it's just just
how it is
but michael fassbender's magneto
i liked it i liked him as my you know i
think he did a really good job so i
wouldn't be disappointed if he showed up
as the magneto
but sergey mckellen um
i think that would be really cool
um to have like an og and then of course
like
another one that would make sense is
toby mcguire spider-man
now of course you could have andrew
garfield spider-man
that that wouldn't matter either but i
just think because toby's so
original right from the original
spider-man films
i don't know if paul bettany would
want to work with toby hey
sean hames thank you so much for that
super chat appreciate that
woof woof um i'm trying to think of
somebody that
paul bettany would really love to work
with and and when i when i
when i hear that when i say that out
loud i think patrick stewart
or ian mckellen like those are the two
people i think because they're
amazing actors um from everything i've
heard i don't know them they're good
people
um they're both knighted so
to the to me those make sense um
and magneto continuity wise and
story-wise being the father
of wanda makes a lot of sense and if we
think about it this way
well this is kind of pushing towards uh
michael fassbender's magneto but it's
the same universe so it could easily be
uh timothy lagrange thanks for the
dinner potato
i don't know what that means if i'm
missing something um
rc blue thanks so much for the donut
thinking we could get a wonder man
name drop today at the end if they say
something like missing person of simon
williams
i think that would be cool yeah i don't
know if you caught my video today
um we know unless marvel's like
completely trolling us
like and they've done it before so
unless marvel's like completely trolling
us we know that wonder man's going to
like be in there at some point in time
now i do think
they're gonna stay somewhat true to the
to the comics in this
and maybe
[Music]
like to rebuild vision they maybe they
took something from wonder man
right because in the comics they take
like his brain waves and brain patterns
that's how they
make vision and then rebuild them
eventually as well so
i'm kind of like i think
the best way that works is if they had
to
it's kind of like it's not the soul
stone it's the mind stone but it's kind
of like a soul for a soul like
if you're gonna try and rebuild vision
you're gonna kind of have to take
another life because vision wasn't
exactly alive
he was an android right i don't know if
he has a soul
per se right we don't really need to
dive into all that stuff but
he was an android right um
so i don't you know i don't know how
that works but i i think if you
probably made it to where it's somewhat
similar to the comics where you need his
brain waves and brain patterns to create
vision or bring it back to life in this
case
um they take it from simon williams
wonder man
and that would explain the grim reaper
easter egg that we got in one division
episode two as well we saw the grim
reaper's helmet
um grim reaper is
simon williams's brother or wonder man's
brother and he hates vision he wants
kill vision because
he's a imitation of wonder man his
brother so
i don't know now in in
infinity war um
it's banner yeah it's banner that talks
about you know the mindset is just one
part of vision
excuse me and there are if you take away
the mindset there are a lot of other
components
that are still left but that was if they
like strategically
took out the mind stone like
shuri used all the wakandan technology
and they took it out very carefully and
i don't remember the number that she
said but you know there was a ton of
numbers like thousands and thousands of
like
neurons attached to him that she had to
take out and that's not exactly what
happened
so i don't know if you can like
reconnect something like that
um i don't know
um i don't know if deadpool could be the
one i don't i don't really think it
would be him
isaiah beltran thanks so much for the um
super chat kind of off topic but you
think mephisto
is going to be the next big bad for um
avengers i do
but as i stated my video today since
china has such like bad connotations
with the devil but i guess everybody
does but like china specifically
um it's like very taboo so if marvel
like
did a devil character china probably
wouldn't be on board with it
and they have a huge audience there
right um millions and millions and
millions of people
so i think that they might do mephisto
and nightmare combined into one
character
maybe um or call him something else but
hey we have a minute so
everybody who has your disney plus out
let's get ready to press that play
button
let's see
[Music]
oh i can't see much i don't know all
right guys it's about to be
be ready to press your play button
because it's coming pretty soon
probably got like 20 seconds is my audio
good
yep all right putting the ear
airpods in can the cameo be from adam
moore like the gamer thanks so much for
super chat yeah i mean it could
anything's possible
uh i don't know if it will make too much
sense but it could alright everybody
refresh your disney plus
oh just kicked me out of disney plus for
some reason
all right there we go uh episode six
38 minutes long here we go
i press play
[Music]
previously on one division
this episode is 38 minutes long
let's see what we find out in this
episode they're just doing a recap right
now
only vibranium synthesizoid
oh i need to plug my computer in
i had a brother pedro
all right sorry i had to plug my
computer in all right here we go
marble marvel intro
new cast magneto mcu version magneto i
hope
all right we're past the intro or the
logo let's go
oh gosh
oh my gosh this is so 90s
[Laughter]
that's pretty good no oh there's agnes
agnes billy maxum off tommy maximoff
pedro maxim off as himself oh gosh that
was so 90s that's insane that's my
childhood right there
yes i will do live stream for falcon in
the winter soldier
he's dressed as his comic book part
halloween episode
ha
a dorkasaurus rex this is the leaked
video part
the leaked audition tape
that's crazy
[Laughter]
wow now he is quicksilver he has all of
his powers
wow he's running super fast
the comic hacker costume i love it
a sokovian fortune teller is what she
says she is
in law
that's so awesome
[Music]
he's a mexican wrestler
okay
rowdy
this shotgun sprite
i'm undercover
vision's still in the neighborhood watch
mom and dad have been different
do you guys want spoilers not spoilers i
you know
it's 38 minutes micah
dude
all right so spoilers i'm going to go
into spoilers people if you don't want
to see
leave i'll give you a little bit taste
quicksilver's there
they're talking and they're about
talking about doing pranks for halloween
right now
vision just left this isn't just left
and he's not going trick-or-treating
with them he's going to do neighborhood
watch stuff
and i'll continue to kind of like show
you bits and pieces
oh look at this
look quicksilver
[Laughter]
they're wearing the same costume the og
quick silver costume from the comics
epic
okay now we're outside of the the energy
[Music]
bubble
so they have the drone that wanda threw
at him and it still has magic around it
so hayward is saying that he had no
choice but to attack
wanda and monica jimmy and darcy are
saying you had no right to do that and
we have no idea what's going to happen
monica just said monica's the problem
she has to be the solution
they just they just said carol danvers
oh snap hey we're just saying you have
no idea what it was like
because he didn't get snapped in the
last five years
oof hey we're just fired monica well i
don't know if you fired her he said
oh all of them so hayward just
kicked out jimmy wu darcy and monica he
said get him off my base
oh jimmy jimmy just punched the sword
agent now they're escaping
heck yeah this is a jimmy i like
jimmy and monica just took out a sword
squad
dude jimmy just decked somebody
that's awesome i love jimmy
i'm not thinking hayden's mephisto or
hayward's mephisto
anymore i'm thinking he's just a bitter
person who hates superheroes
[Music]
halloween
unleash hell demon spawns what
quicksilver said
quicksilver just said i know i look
different wanda said why do you look
different
there's kids everywhere now
all the candy has disappeared
patreon the kids stole all the candy
this episode's awesome
[Laughter]
oh
stop spamming stop spamming ali meddy
please stop spamming
uh apparently quicksilver and his his
niece and
nephew spoil is what happened
this is weird
night monkey proves i'm a fist though
what a 90s commercial
what the incredibles the parent trap
ha i get it
quicksilver says his job is to give her
grief
so
so he is the quicksilver
he is the quicksilver from
age of ultron just in a different body
what maybe just because
evan peters quicksilver was the 80s one
they used him because they were in the
80s
so quicksilver said he got shot up and
then he heard her calling him
and he know he knew she needed him so he
showed
up
darcy jimmy and monica are now their own
team
oh
guys i'm about to do spoilers so i would
click away now if you don't want
spoilers
so hayward has managed to track like
everybody in the town
and he's tracking vision specifically
and vision is getting awfully close to
the barrier
no i don't think mephisto is
impersonating quicksilver
i think it's quicksilver i think it's
the same consciousness as aaron taylor
johnson's quicksilver
just the body of evan peters quicksilver
vision is on the outside of town and the
people aren't really moving
and he's kind of confused why no one's
really moving
i wish i could show it all but i can't
guys it's copyright
so it looks like yeah petro is using his
power
he can run super fast like quicksilver
does
looks like vision's about to try to
break through
i think it's aaron taylor johnson's
consciousness inside of evan peters body
[Music]
whoa oh okay he's just changing
i'll turn the brightness on my screen up
so vision is up above the town looking
over
everything right now like we saw in the
in the trailer
i don't know if you can see that yeah
you're
it's it's too dark of a scene to show
right now oh there you go
all right so he's going to try and break
out now
oh this is going to be agnes
it's agnes sitting in the car from the
sitting in the car from the
from the trailer she's just standing
there
all right it's important
vision's about to awaken agnes
and here it comes here it comes
it's gonna be a huge part
she just said you're one of the avengers
your vision
are you here to help us
he doesn't know he's an avenger
am i dead no why would you say that
she's yelling dead he just yells dead
she just said no one leaves
wanda won't even let us think about it
he's laughing like a big witch now
oh vision just
put her back i'm not buying it
ellis rolling hill
i'm not buying it i think it's an act
i think it's an act i'm not buying it
now there is always the possibility that
she could be good
but i don't know
oh hayward has monica's blood work
the energy inside is rewriting
people's cells and changing them on a
molecular level
that has to be
has to be x-men
that has to be an x-men reference
hey dj elliott thanks so much for the
donut well what
uh well ellis is about to go
or ellis the twit their vision's about
to go past ellis
um it's 38 minutes long
[Music]
you got wanda and quicksilver
he just said i think mom and dad would
have loved it
yeah i'm not sure mambo jazzy
thanks for the dono
i'm trying to figure it out
she says i don't know how i did it
i remember feeling completely alone
that's
that's all she remembers
endless nothingness
oh dead quicksilver with bullet holes
whoa
all right darcy's trying to crack crack
dang it i didn't see the name
no i can't see the name
vision's about to leave or he's about to
try to leave
and besides that darcy was looking at
some computer stuff and i was just
trying to look for easter eggs and try
to see names or something like that
vision's leaving
vision's leaving
vision's out
the vision's out oh they're there swords
there to greet him
very weird noise is being made
vision's out he's not dead
yeah he can't leave
ooh he's being sucked back in
thanks mama jazzy yeah he can't leave
ooh wicked hears him
oh he can read their mind wiccan their
kid can read their minds
oh snap vision's like
trying to leave but he's getting sucked
back in
spoiler
oh he's like legitimately dying
it's not like your dead husband could
die twice and she blasted him
they're trying to find vision now
she just froze everything did she stop
time
dude what just happened
oh she's making the energy field bigger
oh are they all about to get sucked in
oh they're all about to get sucked in
she just expanded the energy barrier
oh they left darcy how rude
[Laughter]
darcy just got sucked in
so did the helicopter oh the helicopter
turned into an air balloon
everybody's getting sucked in
the tank just turned into a funnel cake
truck
oh oh
westview
wow
wow
oh my gosh that's the end no way
oh no oh
no
dude that was sick
oh my gosh okay hold on i gotta get with
the guys now
dude oh my gosh guys that was insane
hold on
i have to get with the peeps now
wow i cannot believe that
i can't believe that that's just insane
how did that even like wow wow wow
wow wow wow wow let's get in this uh
zoom in with everybody hold on
[Music]
let's take these out that was oh
hold on guys hold on oh i can't plug
this in
ah dang it oh well we'll just deal with
it
oh my gosh soups
oh my gosh that was crazy
to be honest i'm kind of underwhelmed no
really i think
well i think that i think that a lot of
my theories are
thrown off now is is why i'm so shocked
i don't think a lot of what i what i
what we were talking about before might
be real
but but i don't i don't dude i don't
know if mephisto's behind it
and if he is i don't think we're gonna
see him in this in this show
yeah bro i don't think it's all her bro
it's all
so here's here's just initially what i
think is happening
i think there are two i think there's
wanda and then i think there's a scarlet
witch
and i think the scarlet witch is her
subconscious and she's the one doing it
and then wanda doesn't really know right
because like she said she doesn't really
remember much
because that's what she does in the
comics like when her subconscious starts
like
changing things so it could
just be her
yeah dude i think it's just her
dude the okay okay well well okay so
what do you think about this
nightmare because of the dead patriot
and then the dead vision before
yeah i think it could be never i think
it could be
nightmare dude i think it might be
nightmare
together i think they're going to
combine their characters
yeah to like where mephisto has like
nightmarish powers
yeah yeah because you know like the
whole china thing that everybody's been
talking about
yeah yeah yeah
probably bro oh my gosh
okay big thing bro we're getting a big
cameo next episode
you think it's next episode bro i mean
monica said she's she has her guy oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
big cameo next episode yeah hawkeye i
think it's hawkeye
fury maybe i mean both those make
sense big happy next episode
yeah i think so i think you're right on
that one i don't think it's the cameo
you know what i'm talking about no
no no it's not the luke skywalker right
right right i don't think it's the cameo
but i'm definitely like
you're right yeah i think you're right
because it's got to be somebody right
they don't just tease somebody
right if it's nobody so
but okay hey what do you think about
this because that to me
this seems like it's actual
aaron taylor johnson consciousness right
yeah like it's his dude like it is him
i wanted to talk about that yeah it's
him it's him
yeah like he still has all of their
memories from when they were kids
like it's literally just evan peters
playing him
right and it's because um when she
brought him back
it was the 80s and he's the 80s version
right
um i mean he kind of mentioned it that
she that she didn't want that grief
right
oh right right right so she changed so
so
that would kind of go against the
multiverse theory right
that she's not it's not quicksilver from
the fox
x-men universe yeah it's just
evan peters's body she's kind of weird
just like i don't understand why
they wouldn't bring back aaron taylor
johnson instead i mean i heard some
stuff that like
and i don't want to say because i don't
know but that like you know there were
some like
not so good things that went down i'm
not saying there was like a scandal or
anything but maybe like an agreement
couldn't be reached or something like
that you know
yeah um yeah this could have definitely
have been an outlet for that
well and i was reading something you
know that um
jack schaefer said when she was talking
to evan peters how he was down to come
back you know
and it was like crazy and stuff like
that and he said you know if it makes
sense
i'm more than happy to come back and
they said that they found like a really
good way for it to make sense
and i think this way actually does make
sense i think
she didn't want to actually see him
like the one that she knew because too
much pain too much
like this whole thing oh what did he say
he said
she found shangri-la
remember that who said that uh
quicksilver he's like you found
shangri-la here
yeah um yeah yeah when they were talking
on the hate on the hey
right so i wonder what that means
i i think it means that just like you
know she
it's anything she wants it to be
and he and he talked the whole entire
time it was pretty revealing episode
actually
yeah really really revealing episode
they were just like directly talking
stuff they weren't avoiding
anything um bro something big is going
down with hayward
yeah so okay i think
we didn't even know about that anymore
yeah and they didn't show like what she
became
right they showed a lot of people become
different things but so
one thing i want to talk about is agnes
i still think she's agatha but
maybe she's good and wanda took control
over her
yeah yeah dude that was a big throw off
for me man like that whole scene with
her and vision like i genuinely like
i think she did i think like want this
mind controlling her as well
right yeah and we're sorry real fast
mambo jazzy thanks for the um
super chat it is it's possible wanda
isn't even in west view she's in a coma
and acting everything some consciously
from a sword facility
wanda wakes up in a promo scene yeah but
it's so hard to tell with the promo
scenes because uh because everything is
you know they they make you
see whatever you want to see hey brad's
here
dude what'd you think yes it was wild
yeah now now we're at the breaking point
this is where the last three episodes
are just out of control yeah that's what
i got
that's what i got they teed it up
and now it's time for everything to come
crashing down
so we were just talking about agnes
because she i was really thrown off this
time by her
i uh i still think she's out of the
heartness but
but in the comics she's actually good
right she's not a villain i mean
sometimes
sometimes but she's actually good so
like she took care of the twins
and she took care of franklin richards
so
so she could be good and she could just
be under one dispel
like she was just a byproduct of it
what do you think i don't know she she's
been such a manipulator this whole time
that you know what's real and what's not
real
right oh sorry uh daniel carson thanks
so much for that donation
i i forgot about this part but pedro
said
go and get some candy demon spawn to the
kids
i'm i was like holy crap he just called
them demon spawns like that's
that's crazy i and yes okay mitchell
perez thank you so much for the super
chat
i did notice that brad we called it bro
um beast mode is just since in a super
chat who do you think monica is
monica's friends she was referring to
next episode we're getting a massive
cameo bro
yeah yeah she said he exactly
that confirmed oh dude if it's reed
richards i'm gonna lose my [ __ ]
oh my god dude it could be that it could
be read man
wait the list is very small at this
point it
i mean but do we think it's the same
person
hawkeye do we think it's the same
because remember the i don't know if you
guys you probably caught this like the
spanish subtitles
was feminine like making it think that
it's a girl
yeah that's what i say that i think her
chat right last last week
so this time she specifically mentioned
a guy so i don't think it's the
aerospace engineer it's someone
different
right i mean maybe i don't know i don't
know um
mitchell perez thanks for the super chat
did you notice that agnes wasn't
completely so like others
she was faking the prior info from
vision that's what i kind of think
um and i was saying that as we were
watching it i was like no
i'm not buying it i think she's faking
it because if you notice after vision
kind of touches her after
she kind of goes right back to normal
like
super quickly just kind of like it was
nothing like she kind of got what she
wanted for vision
and was like she said what she needed to
say right and then she was like okay bye
turn the car around right away
like did it was like okay you were
completely lost before
and then you go back he like disawakens
you and also you're like okay bye have a
good time let me turn the car around and
go right where i'm supposed to go like
i don't think that i don't think that's
what it is
they said kick ass might be a knot to
the wing with evan peters and erin's
johnson oh yeah that's a weird
weird that's very meta and weird because
it's not actually aaron taylor johnson
i mean how many times did i get the i
i'm so it's actually
i i think it's actually but how many
times did agnes say dead
she was like dead dead dead holy crap i
mean
also i really that that shot
of of her like freezing everything
[Music]
dustin roberts thanks for so much for
the super chat also agnes was in the
intro this week
what do you think also the commercial
meaning um yo yeah what about that
commercial
i don't even know like what that
commercial was from so
that to me that was literally saying
yo magic will save you
right yeah her magic we'll see
we'll save her yeah and that's what
she's doing she's creating
her reality with her magic
i think that was really on the nose with
with what they were trying to say i
don't think it was that like
too uh subliminal
or anything like yeah i think it was
straight up like
yo i forgot with the tagline but it was
good
screw this guy hayward like screw this
guy like i want one that's it
yeah how dare you yeah how dare he throw
that in one of his face that she wasn't
there for her mom
yeah he seems just like a very
bitter person that like he had something
happen to his family too
right and he's like i hate superheroes
he's like a zemo
right i want to be surprised if he teams
up with zemo
are we really not going to talk about
how they left [ __ ] darcy
i know they just left her
uh she was uncovering literally i know
ben love thanks for super chat anger is
absolutely part of what's going on she
was clearly trying to get vision to
leave
she seemed like she was faking being
frozen yeah she was at a very specific
point remember the street
wanda said don't go past that street and
then their agatha was agnes was
so that's definitely she's i'm and if
you go
back we can't ignore what happened last
episode that she was like do you want to
do a retake
like you know what i mean like we can't
just ignore that she knows what's
happening
she is more free than everybody what the
same [ __ ] this episode
oh did he yeah he's like you you want me
to change anything
oh i didn't know that well
well herb was with agnes that one time
when they were like
oh because we're all episode three right
um dag official thanks so much for the
donation i really appreciate that super
chat this is crazy boys
a lot of reveals this episode but
marvel's doing a good job
dag thanks so much for the super chat i
think it was really interesting the way
they displayed wiccan's powers for the
first time
yeah we didn't see wicked power wiki's
powers throughout the entire episode
until vision started dying
yeah the oz log thanks for the super
chat doctor strange
be on his way seems like it no he's
there bro
i don't see i don't see how he doesn't
show up by the end
um he's there on some capacity already
yeah and we talked about this last week
where where in far from home and he's
like doctor strange
unavailable it's like yeah he's
definitely unavailable cause this crap's
going down
bro she's swallowing the planet yeah
like literally is taking people in you
know and and now it's going to be how
now it's going to be it's a bigger
threat because how big can she make this
right that's how they're going to view
it
she could cover the whole entire world
and the whole world's going to be you
know
america is going to be under it and the
whole world that's going to be what
hayward's going to say right and this
right now his whole
base got engulfed by this pocket reality
right
right so it's literally monica jimmy wu
hayward and three agents right you're
telling me they're not gonna call it
back up at this point now
yeah and it's not normal hey i need some
sword agents it's like
okay
right yeah this is it like call
in everybody you freaking out she's
gonna be trying to well
she might even call captain marvel seems
like they're kind of bitter right now
about something but
they ain't broken again bro they dropped
her name again
yeah we're getting that is coming and
we're
fight
that fight with her wanda it's so
obvious at this point
i think so dude it's gotta be no i don't
think they're
bringing her in next episode i think
next episode will get that cameo of
whoever monica was referring to
for sure yeah yeah for sure by the way
hold up hold up
oh i know that was like my favorite part
of the whole entire thing
i was like yes i love him even more now
cr1138 thanks for the super chat they
keep mentioning nightmare i think
i think nightmare might be the big one
i i i i i think might make you combine
them
i think it's mephisto and nightmare in
the same one
yeah they're just combining the
characters someone sense
said um do you think vision will
remember darcy when he wakes up
well i don't think vision has ever met
darcy
he hasn't this is an avengers level
threat
this really is indeed guys i have a lot
of super chats i have to thank real
quick can you bear with me
yeah adam jones thank you so much i
wonder what stuff hayward's hiding under
the firewalls on this computer
i'm gonna go take a quick a close look
at every name that there were some names
that popped up
i'm gonna take a look at one of them i i
wonder if one of them's wonder man
one shot thanks for the super chat i
think agatha's working for hayward
yeah there could definitely be a
connection there is especially if we
think that he's you know
this nightmare mephisto combined
guys we need to hey look at these guys
yo
chris what up
we got the squad dressed up for
halloween let's go
come on i gotta we had two headphone
things going so once i can do it
yes yes here wait i'm captain america
there we go
there we go halloween spirit
you're one
jdog film reviews hey what's up man i
really think you could tell wanda
starting to lose control people in the
outside of city are still but everyone
else is walking
yeah i was curious at what what that's
kind of about too like
everybody it almost seems like
because like when it's a show it's like
the people who aren't in the shop
they're just sitting there
kind of doing nothing so i think that
may be why
they're those people on the outside kind
of just standing still
i don't know yeah so
are you talking about how there's like
all those people that are just like
stuff like frozen
yeah yeah so like i don't know i feel
like that's just because they're so far
removed from like where one
is right i agree she's either not
worrying about controlling them or
whoever i think someone has like a
larger hand in the pot here still
but i think that it's mainly one if that
makes any sense yeah
that was the big takeaway from this
episode cam what are you gonna say i
think that
like everything going on is like still a
lot for wanted to handle like that is a
lot of power
to use so wherever she can like minimize
using power
she's gonna and i think that if they're
like all the way out the edge like keep
them not moving because if they wander
around too much
they can hit the edge or something yep
makes sense
oh yeah guys i'm gonna i'm gonna mute
myself real quick to acknowledge some
super chats
sorry so chris cam
thoughts what are your thoughts on this
episode i don't know how to get rid of
their voices guys
[Music]
i'm pissed off i'm not so hold on
there we go so jason jaden david i'm
sorry
commercials to show that people are
starving
and the magic isn't staying i like that
that's actually really good people are
starving and the magic isn't sustaining
them
yeah because are they eating like are
they gonna
are they gonna live like that's a good
question
trabzol thanks for the super chat do you
think that the people in her bubble
could become mutants yeah dude
that that seemed to be like a big mutant
easter egg there right
i'm gonna definitely talk about that in
my video tomorrow but it definitely
seemed like that was like a huge
mutant easter egg right talking about
changing their dna on a molecular level
like
that had to be a mutant easter egg
thanks for the super chat
i hope i pronounced that right i'm sorry
if i didn't think monica was talking
about nick fury
because he's the only ticket there yeah
but i think he might be in
space at this point so i wonder if they
bring in nick fury
if it's going to be talos as nick fury
not actually him
christopher quinones thank you so much
for the super chat wouldn't
what wanda is doing being considered an
avengers level 10 oh absolutely
yeah like they're gonna like think that
she's taking over the world now
raptor films thank you so much for the
super chat i'm fully convinced that reed
richards is a guy i
hope so man i hope he's next episode
maybe not a next episode because
we want him to premiere like the last
episode right adf745 thanks so much for
super chat yeah i need answers too man
uh i'm gonna have to think this over for
a lot the super dark commercial lone
wolf thanks for the super chat yeah
i i like the theory that was stated
before about the magic isn't sustaining
them but i also think that like
yo magic like brad was saying will kind
of get you out of it
if i missed any super chat i deeply
apologize i'm trying to
uh you know talk and theorize with
everybody here
i do not mean to miss any super chats so
i apologize if i do snapped away thank
you one of son was dressed up as doctor
strange
um well i'll have to take a look again
but that's kind of how he looked that's
how he looked in the comics he was
dressed up
as how he looks in the comics jingala is
known rad the silver surfers homeworld
what
really i didn't know that
if it is nightmare what do you think he
wants with wanda
well he could just want someone who
could
oh just thinking about this he could
want somebody to induce fear into
everybody in the world
so so he could feed off the fear because
that's how he needs fear
the gamer thanks for the super chat i
think episode 7 might be 2000 errors to
come
i hope so we're supposed to progress a
decade each time so
gotham 2099. thanks so much for the
super chat
guys i'm sorry if i miss anything i'm
really trying to get them all
oops
agave was moving while she was frozen
as if she were trying to stay still also
peter's acting sus
yeah i know about quicksilver yeah maybe
hmm they mentioned ellis ave a lot this
episode elsa
was the target of magneto's plan to turn
humans into mutants
yeah let me screenshot that so i can
remember that thank you for that
has that has been directly shown in the
actual theme song opening no not since
not since this yeah i do i think and i
again i think that she's playing
i i i don't think that she's nobody i i
think she's agnes
all right i'm sorry i think she's out of
the heartness
again guys if i missed any super chats
i'm so sorry the name is ray johnson on
the computer ray johnson ray johnson
rc blue thanks for super chat wanna
could turn into nightmare love your vids
hey
naxta57 thank you so much i appreciate
that
she could that could be another way that
she kind of goes that or he could
possess her
he could possess her hmm
let's talk okay sorry guys
someone sits in a super chat said wanda
will 100 create mutants by expanding
that field over the world that's what i
was thinking
too yeah that's what i thought was
happening at the end for a second
hey so somebody pointed out in a super
chat that um
when when quicksilver mentioned
shangri-la
they said that shangri-la is the
homeworld of norn rad the silver surfer
j-dog films review things for super chat
yes bro what if that is how the x-men
are formed i think i
i think that's how i think that was a
very
yeah i think that was a very clear um
you know altering your cells and on that
molecular level you know i think that
was very
like in our face about it
damn man that's yeah that scene was kind
of heartbreaking seeing all the vision
just get torn to shreds hoping to sleep
curled into a fetal position
like a win
[Laughter]
man he just wants to help people like
he's so humanized
in the show i feel so bad of course
they're gonna make me
care about him when he's dead right
gtr raider i'll have to look in that
tattoo
i'll have to look into that tattoo bro
thank you guitar raider for that chat at
least the falconer soldier will be a
tiny bit more of a payoff so it'll be a
week for an hour
thomas rice thank you so much i think
that anyone who enters the hex turns to
muted yeah i think so
speed's necklace had 12 balls google it
comes up with how fast money and falcon
has
12 percent chance of winning dang sean
webb that's intense that's meta thank
you for the super chat
ultraviolet possibly but there's
something going on but
us as they were talking about the silver
server earlier like do you 100 think
that reed richards is who they're going
to meet up
monica and jimmy i think nah i don't
think it's 100
i think probably i think it'll be
someone like we know like someone we're
familiar with someone
we've seen before yeah she did she said
um
i have to go meet my guy and i feel like
that
was said to kind of throw us off because
like you can like say you have a guide
or something that could be a girl you
know what i mean yeah
right i have a guy i would you know a
guy
you know
yeah and and that kind of like takes me
back to last episode
where where
dang it norm norm's his name where
vision like awaken norm
and and she didn't say wanda he said she
right yeah marvel usually does that on
purpose
and then someone said um grim reaper
question mark
i like the guy
oh my gosh hold up someone put at 16 49
it looks like nightmare i'm going to
right now thank you for the super chat
by the way phoenix bird gaming
yeah just in time thanks for super chat
herb did say need me to change anything
so he kind of knows too yeah but he was
with
agnes when they were like because we're
all
trapped here whatever he was going to
say just clearly in the know
about something he could be somebody
1649 yeah i've not seen it yeah i'm not
seeing it either
bro this is where this is where the time
stamps start rolling in i know right
back
in that kid that was literally like a
decaying
around corpse same time sam you know
when vision was looking at other people
and he was like ask my lady questions
oh no i didn't see that i'll to go back
and look at that yeah go i don't know
what the
exact timestamp is 16 16 15
maybe
thanks for the super chat evan peters
said x y gene that may be a nod
to the x gene absolutely i think we got
some big x-men things here
yeah for sure big x-men stuff bro
whoa someone someone's
paul winters thanks for the super chat
i'm confused in-game was set when people
were coming back
so how was wanted there for the battle
but well this takes place three weeks
after in game so she was there to come
back for end game
this is three weeks after in game i'm
pretty sure that uh
he looks like jack frost
[Laughter]
that's true christopher quinones why
doesn't vision know the avengers is your
question because he doesn't remember his
life out of west view because
we're going to assume hayward was kind
of telling the truth when wandas or when
he said wanda
took his body and resurrected him well
he said it himself he was like
she never talked to me like this before
and he was like what do you mean before
right before what right i don't
yeah you you know what um oh
i just lost it um someone brought up a
really good point we have not seen
dottie yeah like again yeah
like yeah man is she somebody else and
for agnes to say
she's the key to everything in this town
and then for us not to see her right
zechariah tolson that's who it was
thanks for super chat
yeah she could i i i made a note of that
before this like
because i like made notes to like look
up for things and it was dottie was one
of them cause i was like
we haven't seen her since what episode
two
i mean we saw her in a brief scene in
episode
three like when wada is having kind of
the contractions and she's
like taking out the powers of the whole
town oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah we did yeah we saw him like a very
brief second
but i think it's definitely weird
because
in episode two she was one of the very
few things that had color
and i feel like that has to be
significant like her like when your hand
was bleeding we saw it as red
right yeah that had to mean something oh
oh mamba mambo jazzy thanks for the
donation he just said silver surfer's
home planet is
zen la not shangri-la thanks for that
clarification
yo brad right now if you had to pick
who's this cameo next episode it's
pretty much confirmed at this point
where you're getting a cameo next
episode
if it's if it is in fact a male i think
it's reed richards or
hawkeye hawkeye yeah yeah
yeah kid fresh that's what we're talking
about right now thanks for the super
chat
i think it is hawkeye he'll be the first
to deliver the vehicle himself
yeah yeah who would be giving it to him
he was on the farm
yeah i feel like i feel like it being
hot guy is
like i don't i feel like hockey is gonna
show up 100 but i feel like him showing
up for this is just a tiny bit far
fetched because how would he know monica
because it's monica's guy you know what
i mean like monica's the one that
reached out monica's the one that knows
the person
and she was gone for five years so it
has to be someone that should yeah but
maybe he doesn't well
hawkeye's oh and hawkeye's been with
shield
for a long time so maybe you know i
don't know
i get what you're saying it's a far
connection it's it's far it's
many steps to get that yeah i see what
you're saying he's not 134.
1034. what i'm saying though is like
hawkeye might know the person that she
talked to
immediately and then junks thanks so
much for the super chat
i'm going to lose my mind too man i will
absolutely lose my mind
max cutler did you guys notice at the
movie theater it said incredibles i did
see that
incredibles are based off the fantastic
there's
it's not a coincidence that's
intentional max cutler thanks so much
for that i'm gonna screenshot that so i
remember that for my breakdown thank
right you i said that in the show next
to 57
thanks for the donation well it looks
like wanda goes bananas and scarlet
witch takes over with mephisto
and she's streaming that yeah dude
i think so next uh thank you like thanks
for saying that because i think so
you know uh infinity shades
thanks for the donation i am gonna check
that out for sure
uh his tattoo
yeah just in time thanks for dono i know
gotham 29.99 thank you so much for the
donut we have seen her
with the mines yeah
maybe maybe it did give her more power
i think that yo magic commercial is huge
story reveal
someone needs to eat wanda's magazines
by maybe lj williams we'll look into
that
petrol asking wonder where were you
keeping all the other kids i know tim
wonder thanks for that i appreciate that
please shield has to get involved in
episode seven because it looks like well
i think sword is shield now the gamer
and thanks for the donation and the text
is how he gets his powers
barrett's saying he is the ex-wife
university chromosome and the demon
spawn comment
he is the father he is also nightmare he
could yeah you know i really think he
might be
gtr raider 84 thanks for the donut i
really think that might be the case
hawkeye would want one to bring back
yeah the theoretical film
assist thanks for doing it that's that's
true he would
might be quintons but google marvel r4
123 and one of the images that it
suggests for testing for issue oh
i'm going to screenshot that thanks for
the dono thanks for the tip victor
herrera i'm going to look into that
22 yeah so
i wouldn't be surprised if we see them
beforehand and they're doing disney
shows left and right so yeah they are
big man cam
thanks for the super chat mentions that
if if captain marvel and wanda would
fight
the like the cataclysmic energy from
that would be insane because they both
got their powers from
infinity stones please but once again
are you
seriously telling me that the avengers
and captain marvel
and the big guns aren't aware that now
the pocket reality has just grown even
bigger
which means it's even stronger yeah
well and we've talked about this in
previous discussions
doctor strange's whole sole purpose as
he mentions an infinity war is protect
the reality he 100 knows what's going on
right now he has to yeah
yeah yeah i wonder if he's like you know
how they're like giving us different
perspectives i wonder if they're going
to switch to doctor strange one time
just like sitting in the sanctum
just like watching like through a device
and then be like all right now it's time
to
go like at the end of episode eight
episode just ends with doctor train's
the easiest way to get into the hex i
think would just be for doctor strange
just open up before
oh yeah yeah yep for sure thanks for the
donut big man cam
super appreciate that jesse garcia
how you feel thanks for the donation
that's been the whole show right like
uncovering monsters so things that that
have already happened
thanks ej ruiz we're getting to the
hayward stuff i think it's a different
cameo
not the big cameo yet he's been hiding
behind the scenes
dj ruiz thank you he wants vision's body
maybe when wanda first created the
reality and like
i like they like obviously pop up on dr
trinity
the gamer i know right i wish you
wouldn't say that he didn't even
says you're wanna conquer yeah
gary lopez thank you he's in there gary
lopez thank you
that's a great that's a great that's a
great thought
victor by the way project is the name of
one of the medical files
oh gotcha i'm going to write that down
thank you so many good shots in this
episode
yeah the shots of her eyes though they
almost
like i don't know why he hasn't said you
didn't see that come in the gamer
like gary lopez a ritual i like that
guy's like that's
chaos magic bro that's what i'm saying
like that's not true well and i just got
a super chat that mentioned
when when uh quicksilver says that
he kind of like heard her name that
could have been like a summon
like a summoning you know like that
could be like yeah like she called
right she called for him right like that
from the dead
yeah right like from dead like holy crap
i'm still like i got to confuse me in
this episode oh hold up
someone said they're agnes sorry
someone said at 10 40 there's a kid in
the background
who has like an iron man bag 10 40.
probably makes sense i mean i was
expecting like oh yeah he does
dude it's a little like iron man helmet
halloween like basket
yeah oh yeah i see it
it's like his head's a little fanny pack
that's nice
so are we gonna see this quick silver
say you didn't
see that coming no
no i don't think so i feel like this
it would feel so wrong to hear such an
american
the whole quicksilver thing is so weird
oh but talk about that situation like
what are we
what's happening with this version of
quick so it's also weird because he
keeps breaking the fourth wall
yeah and remember he was like and he was
like what happened to your
know it's weird i like agnes was in
the theme song of this episode right
yeah
it was barely the episode which i just
i find weird and i feel like she was uh
she was very much around kids in the
last episode
yeah and this thing happened this
episode with uh
pietro like he was kind of around the
kids trying to be friendly
to get the kids on the kids
for sure
on a gravestone it says janelle
samelman and she's a writer for
fantastic foreign spiderman
on a gravestone at 2009. how do people
catch these things
dude you guys are insane i love you guys
yeah that's wild
at 2009
are you sure it's 20 or 9 29
i'm not seeing it yeah madison burns
thanks for the super chat is monica got
her power suppressing the barrier
yeah i do think these people are gonna
get some genetic mutations and powers
some somehow i don't know what they're
going to be but we'll see thanks for the
super chat yeah ed
um there wasn't a great stone matt
pachesco pachetto
thanks so much feel like hawkeye will be
in show one point because the connection
with wanda and stared at ultron
reed will have the vehicle i hope
but but i think it might be hawkeye
that's got the vehicle
brent's lucky slot channel thank you so
much sorry because
my answer was agnes just faking yeah i
think she was i can't answer for sure
but i i think she was faking
billy was dressed up like gamut jesse
robinson thanks for the
uh the super chat well he was kind of
dressed up like he
like wiccan's costume in the comics
but i did think that at first too hey
aiden atkins thanks so much for that
donation i super appreciate that
you guys are all awesome i love you all
i'm trying to get them all guys i really
am i'm so sorry if i miss any
i appreciate them all so much though
tommy billy talking directly to the
camera i know adam thanks so much for
that donut that was crazy
brought up where all the children in
west view there are none of them
but he wasn't there for that
conversation
so like it was just weird because like
no one's breaking the fourth wall
like him and vision right yeah yeah
like what's going on with their
characters like with vision obviously we
know like once he goes outside
he's he's dead so like i'm pretty sure
the same thing would happen to pietro
like but like like wanda never got
vision's body
i mean not not vision's body pedro's
body yeah
yeah blood could be recasted
and the thing is is it's much easier to
bring a robot back to life
that too yeah especially if
like other people were in the process of
already trying to bring it back to life
because he was being dissected five
years after he was already dead
in sword so they were probably already
working on stuff like that
but i feel like i don't know if vision i
don't know if he
was like you know collapsed into a field
position when he left
because of the fact that he was already
previously dead i feel like it was more
or less that he just doesn't have the
strength
to break through wanda's barrier so i
feel like when she walked back in
after the last episode when it all
turned red that was her making it like
10 times stronger than it already was
yeah so i feel like vision doesn't like
jeffy reacts thanks so much for that
donation it definitely is an avengers
level three
nobody has the strength to push through
that and that's why it was like
because we saw it like suck and keep
packing yeah
yeah it did kind of look like it was
dusted yeah
oh oh okay okay the gravestone is at
um 28.00 four and spiderman wow
28.09 yeah 2809. yeah you can see right
there it says the name fully
good catch guys so
mambo jazzy thanks for the super chat
just said that shangri-la
is a top secret shield facility in china
aka tahiti
that brings people back to life
if quicksilver went there that's
definitely an easter egg it is
definitely an easter egg
that's very interesting they're so meta
it's
amazing it's just wild dude
i wanna i wanna see hayward get mashed
up more than anyone
what was the name i'm sorry i it was uh
simmelman now
okay
yeah they're doing an insane job at
packing these things just loading these
things up with the easter eggs
yeah so that confirms that we're going
to see reid richards and toby right
right confirm
[Applause]
the gamer thanks for the donut i feel
like vision wakes up quicksilver you'd
act like
this like you know i know we were
talking about that
yeah yo yo warren warren hold the boy i
gotta hear your thoughts on that the
toby tweets bro
start coming out last night so i talked
to daniel and
i've talked i've talked to charles i
don't talk to him frequently i talk to
daniel frequently
um i would say that's good to go
i would say that based off of those two
track record and who they know i would
say that's a go
i don't know because i know some people
were talking
um i don't know if there will be a trade
announcement though like i don't know if
deadlines gonna
like come out and say hey here we go
guys i feel like marvel and sony would
want that to be like
i feel like that's what we've been
waiting for because like we've known for
a while that like they're coming back
it's just a matter of just like people
went public with the story
right yeah the gamer things were super
chat he just said i feel like if vision
wakes up quicksilver he'd act like the
x-men version of himself
that'd be cool to see that would be
pretty cool to see
do you think that billy and tommy are
scared are gonna become scared of wanda
like
a thousand percent yeah because they saw
her like after
she blasted pietro they're kind of like
a
mom yeah they were you know what was
really funny about that
is there was a leaked audition tape of
one of the twins
and they said the exact same dialogue
about waking
uncle quicksilver i remember i was like
oh quicksilver's coming back because
there's a leaked video and they're
talking about their uncle
which has to be quicksilver and it was
literally like word for word
from the leaked video that was that came
out it was kind of cool that's kind of
cool to see
i also thought it was a clever detail
when
the pocket reality is taking over the
sword base
where she turned everybody into clamps
and the whole thing into a circus
yeah just so clever yeah
thomas henderson thanks for the super
chat one had a mental break
hayward asked about other names she may
have snapped and created a second p
like called scarlet witch she calls
herself a
sword they explain why yes
drag it out as long as possible because
once it's over
yeah thomas henderson i agree with you
and thank you so much for that dono
dorian wilson thanks so much for the
super chat if the infinity stones were
reduced to atoms they still exist means
one it could bring back vision
pedro is definitely mephisto ryan cam
thanks for that donut super appreciate
that
zar thanks so much for that or uh max
conrad thank you so much
so the people who are sucked in remember
anything
do you think the grim reaper will
american parents i think yes to both
i think yes to both thank you for the
super chat yonder beer
bear thanks for that super chat cataract
was a stage in x-men's vs street fighter
very meta i've gotta have to
i'm gonna have to screenshot that thank
you for that thank you for the super
chat
thank you thomas anderson i know i
addressed you just want to say thank you
again
matt hutch thanks for the super chat a
quick silver's brought back to life
it was still alive after getting lit up
makes sense why hawkeye stayed with his
buddy at the oh that makes sense too
yeah maybe
maybe yeah like the first three episodes
were like all right
it's a good thought please look at 1034
and peep who's watching
the here perspective seeing quicksilver
getting more questions and just like
thoughts or just like answers about like
how this all went down
in this episode we actually got that
conversation with one that was like
a quicksilver like how did this all
start and that's when she was like
you know i felt so lonely i just
remember being so sad
and then you know we got more answers in
this episode and now going into seven
we this we were left off on a
cliffhanger
and now we know there's cameos coming
we know i mean we don't even know where
they stand in terms of the alternate
reality with vision
i feel like we didn't we're at like a
stance though i feel like we didn't
necessarily get answers
we more or less just narrowed down
narrowed down
narrowed down our suspicions you know
what i mean
yeah we have x amount of theories we
didn't necessarily get any answers to
any of our questions
it just eliminated a few of those
theories
the even more exciting is the fact that
think of all the trailers or all the
footage we've seen so far i think that
there's only a few shots left that are
gonna be probably in episode seven
but after that i'd say they haven't
shown us anything from the last two if i
had to guess
i agree yeah i agree hey guys check this
out nicolas preda thanks for the super
chat please look at 10 34
and peep who's watching her it actually
looks like
like a grim reaper or like
on her left on her left
thanks for that super chat nicholas it
does look pretty crazy
adam grey thanks for super chat pedro
seems to have different memories from
wanda
the shadow memory she doesn't remember
that way later he does i noticed
that he did step around that there were
a lot of really weird halloween
costumes there was their mamamoo
inflatable horses
i'll have to check that out thanks chris
hassan
um and it looks like there's a doctor
strange one here too yeah we got some
great shots in this episode
in that same 10 34 clip is that like a
doctor strange costume behind her i
can't
no it's not just kidding uh somebody
said chris hassan
there's a de mambo inflatable somewhere
yeah come on i want to put it past
marvel
there's no way we would have seen it
but once again everything in this
reality is tied to
wanda yeah i don't think we have another
model
did i just see hold on what
no that can't be hold on by the way
seeing quicksilver and the kids interact
man like that was great
i got a double chemistry
and the relationship i loved it as well
but like i'm ready to find out
what quicksilver this truly is if that
makes any sense like
oh we all are i mean it's
it feels like too good to be true almost
alex shows vlogs thanks so much for that
i don't know it says message retracted
so i don't know what it says
he looks like group terry okay
sorry if i can't pronounce that the big
shock was some picture called the kid's
demon spawn i know
that that means something it has to
i refuse to believe it doesn't notice
the sixth episode is halloween
fake reality
oh yeah okay thanks sean webb does it
say that
yeah there's like a drawing on the
fridge
and um it looks like the tree the tree
kind of looks like group
like a baby group
but it could just be a tree guys like
guys this is going to seem weird but
at 10 43 i'm seeing somebody in the
background
is this sub-zero from mortal kombat
totally off-topic yeah 10 43-44 there's
a kid in the background
and it looks like sub-zero costume
or maybe just a blue ninja i don't know
10
43 yo it does look like sub-zero right
is that sub-zero oh okay wait hold on
hold on hold on
chris no no no no i know it's nice it's
not okay because you see it in frame
when
quicksilver like runs past them
okay wait hold on real fast so christmas
on donated again thank you
22 31 dormammu inflatable thank you
thank you for the gaming kyrie
thank you guys for the super chess
yeah that i mean i just wonder if that's
a door mama inflatable or if it's like
some halloween thing but it definitely
does look like a thermal inflatable
it's at 22 31.
it's like right there in your face too
like if you if you freeze it right on it
people are saying that at 2809 i can't
really see it
um but at 2809 on the tombstone that
pietro crushes when wanda sends him
flying back
it says banner at the bottom hayward
eagles mephisto
and weird skin boot boy is toad
it's hard maybe i i think i think he's
definitely a villain
306 silver is ghost-like his feet are
blurred
i think he's death a villain no accent
alex shows
vlogs thank you so much i'm gonna check
that out 306.
no
it's stark that would have been i see
that
but maybe that's because he's like
moving really fast
stark ben benjamin parker
so hold on i feel like also i'm gonna
go back to that montel jb semi-man is
one of the directors of the show
james gad and james alexander both work
with marvel 2
the names in darcy's emails so they're
just not oh gotcha
thanks for that i'm going to have to
screenshot that everything
piano coming in town would not miss all
the dynamic
vision in london
tj lewis thank you for the super chat
they make it a point of the mind stone
doesn't deteriorate while the rest
division does
why i know they don't show what happens
with darcy and yeah you're right they
don't maybe it is real
if anything i feel like she's being
gaslit into thinking that she's the one
that did all this and it's not her
raptor films did you notice that evan
coogser was so rude and his hair sticks
straight up just like mephisto in the
comics
and he mentioned demons in the 2000s
24 jackals thanks for the donation
2459 chosen emo content
james d i did some research james
darnold shut up something
not that 147 creepy guys comes
not that comes like right off of my mind
um
so i'll have to look at that project
cataract will explain why the credits
always have an individual's eyes oh that
yeah that makes sense stephen schultz
yeah the guy's just staring at one of
the screens inside yeah
guys if i miss any i'm so sorry i think
that's a statue guys
i think he's tied to the poll like i
don't
[Music]
yeah but it still could mean it's still
like foreshadowing right he has a really
locked house
definitely a decoration purpose but
definitely strange for sure
i still can't believe we don't know who
ralph is imagine if they don't have any
so yeah maybe because you know how like
sorry go ahead
i'll just say imagine there's just like
no big big surprise
with that and it was just like a bit i'd
be so mad well they do that in old
sitcoms
they they reference people that never
really show up
they did it in seinfeld they did it in
uh
well they kind of did in friends with
ugly naked guy but you eventually
saw him you didn't see his face but you
saw him but they've done that like an
old sitcom so
i wouldn't put it past them yeah this
should be annoying
oh i totally would but i wouldn't push
past
vincent rodriguez wow thank you so much
for that 30 super chat i really
appreciate that
thank you so much uh
welcome listen it's 4 30 for us and we
have to film a quick video
and edit it to get it out before we go
to bed
um thank you for having fun it was
really fun
guys
it was great talking to you guys yeah
we're talking to you guys great to meet
you
thank you so i have someone here sean
brower thanks for the donation pedro is
a sword ai
sent in to gain intel i would more along
the line say that he's mephisto
yeah darcy becomes
doctor strange you didn't hear from me
thanks el nini for that super chat that
would be pretty funny
darcy doctor strange
confirmed did we see any pets throughout
the entire episode
like anyone walking i don't know
any rabbits
i don't know okay predictions next
episode
okay wait sorry there was one more thing
i wanted to check out and thank you mdm
review
so a bunch of people said that there's
uh h
o m tattoo on quicksilver at 623 house
of m
i thought it was mom h-o-m
yeah i see it but i just accidentally
exited my player hold
on you thought it was mom yeah on his
left shoulder well let's take a look-see
that's that's mom to me that's m-o-m
yeah i think that's mom i saw that as
well
yeah it's maybe an h i don't know
the right side of it is slanted down and
it's not straight
yeah it does look like mom
but maybe they're really trying to
confuse no whoa whoa
no no no if you pause it at 6 27 it kind
of does look like an h
oh yeah you still see mom oh you
couldn't see mommy
forget it wait wait uh they did make it
a point to not show the whole thing
marvel's so good at that
like i really thought since we're seeing
quicksilver and like seeing him interact
with the kids
seeing how he was like you know just
like the five he was giving off
i thought like i genuinely thought like
it was a fox quicksilver for a second
yeah cause he was talking like
he was talking normal he wasn't talking
like how he was talking at the beginning
of last episode
like a surfer dude yeah yeah
oh here edgar lizarraga thanks for the
dinner he says that
the tattoo could mean multiverse of
madness
now that yeah that would be why
because i don't i mean i guess you'd get
a mom tattoo right i mean
you love your mom but that's that's
intentional right that's
i i say it's a node too
yes jiu jitsu thanks for the donation
thank you so much
10 34. eddie terrell
monica cells have changed what if by
widening the barrier wand is creating
mutants
has been reversed i think so eddie trail
thank you
i think so i like that idea of mutants
reversed
bruh someone was like um uh
1034 green goblin hobgoblin easter egg
it's just like pumpkins
kevin downing thanks for the donation
what is up with herb
he's mentioning each of the pranks that
the quicksilver pool before they
happened
that is true i they were talking about
the pranks before they happened i did
notice that i was like
he's literally doing it like right
behind you as it's happening
so i mean clearly her because of what he
said at the end like
yeah i don't remember the exact quote
but you know basically asking her the
same thing
agnes did if you want to change
something it's pretty intense
thank you vincent rodriguez for that
donation that's super awesome of you
oh man well guys yeah i got a lot to
dissect right now my brain's kind of
overwhelmed
i think they might have given us more in
this than they've given us than the
other ones
detail-wise yeah yeah there's a lot of
stuff we have to go back to i'm gonna
rewatch the episode now
yeah me too anyways guys thank you guys
for tuning into the live stream we
appreciate you guys
we're gonna be back over here for
episode seven next week so make sure to
tune in next week next week thank you
guys for watching we love you guys three
thousand and we'll see you guys next
time
soups brad see you guys next week
uh what am i doing here all right
come on whoop
all right guys wow
um again i just want to say if i missed
any super chats
any donations tonight i i deeply
apologize i
i tried to get every single one i can
while also trying to uh
you know talk with everybody else going
did i miss this one
victoria pacino how does quicksilver or
patreon no vision died
so here's what i think is actually
happening with him i think it's
aaron taylor johnson's quicksilver from
age of ultron i think it's his mind his
consciousness
and the body of evan peters quicksilver
i don't know why maybe to like so wanda
could have brought him there without
like the grief or something like that
um i don't
i don't know the reason why but i do
think it's like his mind but at the same
time
i i think he could be mephisto
like or nightmare or whatever you know
like i
i think he really could because he
mentioned the demon child
and you know things like that so
i mean that's a lot
it's a lot but he clearly has some
memories um
he knew he got shot up and died right he
knows some childhood memories
wanda kind of started to test him on
that but then it like cut off and he
stopped answering questions so
something's up with him something's up
with him
um
10 34 hobbly hob goblin easter egg
person in the hoodie
see again oh yeah
definitely looks like it
definitely looks like a hobgoblin easter
egg just because of the slant of that
right i mean
all right oh guys
oh
dang shane martin voto thanks so much
for the donation for the super chat i
super appreciate that
oh man guys there's a lot of this i
think my biggest confusion of this
episode is agatha
or agnes i'll try to keep calling her
agnes until
they come out and say she's agatha but
i think she was faking it
but i'm not sure 1449 fantastic foursome
on the background
that'll be kind of crazy let's check
that out
um i'm not seeing it off the top of
like what i'm looking at here but i'll
i'll definitely do a a quick look at it
druv agarwal i do remember you
he mentioned being a father figure
thomas henderson thanks for the super
chat
a lot there's a lot to dissect here
he did mention that
shane martin photo having peter's a mom
tattoo in real life on his left arm
oh well
well he did have quicksilver's powers
you know he he was running really fast
around everybody
but who knows who knows
um but if he does have that in real life
then
you know they could always cover it up
so they left it for a reason
why did agnes awaken as she isn't under
control matt pachetta thanks for the uh
dono i think she was faking it
i think she was there for a specific
reason
to like push vision towards the edge or
monitor him or do something
i think she was faking it because at the
end when she like
got released from this or like when she
got put back under it
she like knew right away she knew right
away
what to do so before she was like acting
all confused like
oh town square blah blah blah she gets
awakened
and then she gets put back under and
when she gets put back to under she's
not nearly as confused she's like
oh yep gotta go blah blah blah see ya
and she laughed like a witch
dude thanks for saying yeah she did
laugh like a witch
um
i think one is going to create mutant
mutants with
her hex i think that's how it happens
which is so cool to think about
i think that's definitely how the
mutants come to the mcu i think that
would be so cool
all right well guys i got a lot to break
down i got a lot to look over
i got a recorded video for tomorrow for
my breakdown and it's going to be edited
and uploaded
all that stuff so i will catch you guys
tomorrow
in my video and we'll do a live stream
again next week at the same time
same place thursday slash friday morning
at uh it's it's 3 37 for me
i don't know what time it is for
everybody else but uh it's pretty late
for me so i'm gonna start on this video
for my breakdown for tomorrow
come back here next week and we'll do it
all again thank you to everybody who
showed up tonight and also thank you
to everybody who donated as well i super
appreciate any support for the channel
whether that's
just watching a video hitting the like
button hitting the subscribe button
giving the donut and a super chat i
appreciate
everything so much you guys are awesome